vaccinating our hospitality workers
governor sysolak held a news conference
today to talk on the efforts to
protect those who are on working on the
front lines here in las vegas and across
the state
sasha loftis joins us from the las vegas
strip with more on the governor's
message
governor select says his goal here is to
make all of southern nevada safer and he
says
that starts with hospitality workers
here on the las vegas strip and really
all across our community
whom he calls the backbone of our
economy the governor joined the chair of
the gaming control board
and other state industry leaders here at
the mandalay bay convention center
the governor says the site has
administered at least 5
000 shots so far and gaming leaders
believe at least
100 000 industry workers have been
reached all across the state
now governor sessalak also spoke about
how these efforts
are helping our economy come back people
ask me when will nevada be back
or what when will vegas be back to all
those who ask
the comeback is here now we are on our
way back
and we are on our way back stronger and
safer
and healthier than ever brynn gibson the
chair of the nevada gaming control board
says some of our state's
largest gaming operators are reporting
60
to 70 percent vaccination rates among
their employees
now governor sisilak thanked everyone
who has gotten vaccinated but
he says our work here isn't done he's
asking anyone who has gotten those shots
to really encourage their friends their
family members their poll workers to get
vaccinated as well
so we can reach herd immunity here
locally faster
reporting from the las vegas strip
tonight sasha loftis 8 news now